well the problem is is that there's zero
advantage to marriage in the western
world for a man there are zero
statistical Advantage if you use your
mind if you use your head instead of
your heart and you look at the
advantages of getting married there are
absolutely not really none because this
new idea of new age feminism just
basically destroys all men and the idea
in the event of her leaving and and it's
very common that women leave right let's
let's stop the man versus woman attack
etc etc life's difficult for everybody
we all have different challenges
different things to go through but if a
woman marries a man and it goes wrong
she has emotional heartbreak fine but if
a man marries a woman and it goes wrong
he has emotional heartbreak plus
everything he has ever worked for is
ripped out from underneath them and he
has to give that chick money forever and
some places you don't even have to be
married exactly that's why the men don't
want to live with the women that's right
so when you make these rules and these
laws right under the guise of feminism
and equality all this garbage all you're
doing is scaring men away from
commitment